je veux que tu avais de la visite oui
une anglaise a loué le vieux côte est
juteux travailleurs n 7 anglais sont
ceux qui sait quel âge a votre petit
fils elle est de ce désir vraiment
désolé pourquoi faut toujours que tu
protèges comme si elle était morte parce
que les marques et les honore
je sais pas ce que vous espérez trouver
ici mais cette ville n'est pas près d'en
ouvrir d'anciennes blessures
je suis pas journaliste alors vous êtes
qui merde
on n'a jamais retrouvé le corps de mon
fils
vous pouvez pas continuer de fouiner
comme ça tout seul il n'y a pas que des
gentils abilene
pour avoir arrêté de chercher mon fils
[Rires]
on était censé fauché ce champ récoltait
la canne à sucre le lendemain de
l'accident
ne fera plus jamais
je parle à ma petite violet tous les
jours alors c'est ça que vous faisiez
l'autre nuit denjean
[Musique]
ce sont tous des anges
et il ne nous quitte jamais vraiment
ce que vous avez vous c'est dans votre
tête fils est dans ce plus tard
[Musique]
mais gagner c'est tout là dedans
ce pack la bave rendre complètement
cinglé
si c'était votre au fond vous laisseriez
tomber vous
[Musique]